vamos a hacer algunos ejercicios más
acerca de la pendiente de una recta así
que déjenme piensa en un ejercicio vamos
a pensar que tenemos los puntos 2,5
cuál será menos 33 tenemos menos 3 - 3
mejor tenemos estos dos puntos y lo que
quiero hacer es encontrar la ecuación de
la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
así que bien pues lo primero que podría
hacer sería graficar los puntos así que
el punto 25 estoy dos en la dirección x
y cinco en la dirección y así que estoy
por ahí
más o menos y menos tres a menos tres
menos tres coma menos tres
estoy justo aquí
bien entonces quiero encontrar la
ecuación de la recta que pasa por estos
dos puntos la recta que pasa por estos
dos puntos se ve algo así
bueno claro continua
continúa en todas direcciones bueno no
en todas continúa en ambas direcciones
espero que no se vea muy chica pero más
o menos se ve algo así esta recta y
quiero encontrar su pendiente así que
bien recuerden de los ejercicios que
hemos hecho antes y de la definición de
pendiente que la pendiente se define
como el alza entre el avance cuanto me
alcé por cada unidad que avance en la
dirección actriz eso también lo puede
escribir como el cambio en la rom
y eso también lo puede escribir como el
cambio en / / el cambio en x así que
vamos a suponer que este punto es mi
punto final es decir que quiero llegar a
este punto de acá saliendo el punto aquí
y entonces quién sería entonces quién
sería mi cambio en y pues sería mi final
es decir 5 - milla inicial es decir
menos -3 dividido entre mi cambio en x
cuál fue mi x final pues vale 2 y mi x
inicial vale menos
menos 3 así que sería 2 - menos 3 que
sería lo mismo que cinco más 3 que es 8
dividido entre dos más 3 que es 5 así
que mi pendiente es ocho quintos también
lo podría haber calculado a partir de
este dibujo si estoy saliendo de este
punto del -3 como a menos tres y quiero
llegar al punto 25 entonces digamos que
empiezo aquí y tengo que subir hasta
donde tengo que llegar al mismo nivel en
que este punto así que tengo que llegar
hasta esta línea así que subo subo todo
esto
sube sube sube sube
subo todo esto ese es mi cambio en g
qué cuánto vale vale 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
me cambio en es igual a 8
y cuál es mi cambio en x
me cambio en x es moverme desde este
punto hasta
hasta acá la composición de esos dos
movimientos me hace llegar a mi punto
extinto de destino al punto 25 así que
este es mi cambio en x
y vale 1 2 3 4 5 así que de nuevo tengo
8 entre 5 y noten que también en
realidad podría haberlo calculado podría
haberlo calculado primero yéndome hacia
acá
primero me muevo en la dirección x y
después moviéndome en la dirección y es
más incluso podría haberme ido en
sentido contrario podría haber salido a
este punto y llegar a este pero en ese
caso me cambio en x sería negativo y me
cambio en jet sería negativo también así
que en cualquier caso hubiera obtenido
una pendiente de ocho quintos ok ya que
tengo la pendiente puedo encontrar la
ecuación de la recta que pasa por esos
dos puntos pues recuerden que la recta
que pasa por esos dos puntos y que tiene
pendiente m que es ocho quintos o en
general la ecuación de una recta es de
la forma igual a mx + b donde m es la
pendiente así que en este caso m vale
ocho quintos si sustituyo porque sé que
la recta paso por el punto 2.5 si
sustituyó igual a 5 y x igualados con
emi igual ocho quintos puedo obtener el
valor de b
así que hagamos esto tendría que 5 es
igual a 8 quintos
por dos más ve
pero de aquí puedo despejar y obtener
que b es igual a cuanto pues ya se juntó
todo obtendría 25 menos 16
quintos
qué cuánto es esto pues 25 menos 16 es 9
y el 5 simplemente se queda igual 9
quintos b es igual a 9 quintos de modo
que la ecuación de la recta
la ecuación de esta recta va a ser igual
a la ecuación y es igual a 8 quintos y
pendientes ocho quintos de x + d + 9
quintos
y esta de aquí es la ecuación de la
recta noten que 9 quintos está muy cerca
de los 29 quintos es 1.8 es uno con
cuatro quintos que es 1.8 y lo podría
escribir el decimal pero también está
bien dejarlo así en fracción así que la
ecuación de esta recta es igual a 8
quintos de x + 9 quintos bien pues ya
que tengo este ejercicio vamos a hacer
otro más aquí ya tengo preparado otro
eje cartesiano otro plano cartesiano
perdón ok entonces ahora voy a querer
encontrar la ecuación de la recta que
pasa por los puntos 2 como menos 3
- 4,5 cuál será la ecuación de esos 2
racing los invito a pausar el vídeo y
tratar de tratar de resolver esto por su
cuenta y comparar sus resultados con lo
que me dará a mí así que bien primero
graphic hemos nuestros puntos 2 como
menos 3 2 en dirección x positiva y 3 en
dirección de negativa estaríamos en este
punto de aquí luego menos 4.5 menos 4 en
dirección x y 5 en dirección
así que esos son mis dos puntos mi recta
entonces sería algo así
sería algo así
de nuevo perdonen si esto queda un poco
chueco es un poco difícil de utilizar
esta herramienta para hacer líneas
prolongadas pero creo que se ve bastante
decente así que bien primero que nada
cuál es la pendiente de nuevo la
pendiente es el cambio en
la pendiente es el cambio y dividido
entre el cambio en x mi cambio y si digo
que vamos a decir que
este es mi punto final y este es mi
punto inicial así que me cambio y sería
mi punto final menos 3 terminó en menos
3 en la dirección y menos mi coordenada
inicial que es 5 así que menos 3 menos 5
dividido entre mi cambio en x mi x final
fue 2 hoy dos menos mi x inicial que es
4 menos 4 perdón
así que cuánto me da esto menos 35 es
menos 8
2 - menos 4 sería dos más cuatro que es
6 menos ocho sextos pero recuerden menos
8 sextos lo puedo reducir y obtener
menos cuatro tercios que quiere decir
esto pues quiere decir que si bajo
cuatro unidades en dirección y me muevo
tres unidades en dirección x de
cualquier punto en la recta llegó a un
punto en la recta vamos a checar eso si
salgo de este punto y me muevo cuatro
unidades en la dirección negativa es
decir una dos tres cuatro y luego me
muevo tres en la dirección x positiva
debería llegar a un punto en la misma
recta
23 llegó a este punto que si está sobre
la recta así que esto está bien de modo
que la ecuación de mi recta debe ser de
la forma que es igual a la pendiente
menos cuatro tercios por equis más d
entonces tengo que determinar ve y yo sé
que el punto 2 - 3 está en la recta así
que podría sustituir estos valores y
despejar para ver así que tendría menos
3 es igual a menos cuatro tercios de 2 +
b y de aquí no tengo que ver es igual a
- 9 + 8 entre 3
qué es lo mismo que menos un tercio
de modo que la ecuación de mi recta será
ye es igual a menos cuatro tercios
de x menos un tercio y chequeamos que si
funciona si sustituyó de igualdad menos
3 y x igualados entonces que obtengo
menos 3 es igual a menos cuatro tercios
por 2 menos un tercio menos cuatro
tercios por 2 es menos ocho tercios
menos un tercio es menos nueve tercios
menos nueve tercios es simplemente menos
tres así que esta ecuación funciona y
esa es la ecuación de mi recta
nos vemos en la próxima